I would like to tell you in events that
you're going to hear me say the S word a
lot and you're going to hear me say the
F word a lot too so if some of you are
sensitive about this words you may want
to leave right now
okay I'm going to talk to you about
success and failure what is failure
what is this effort that people talk
about all the time I would like you to
cop lights if you think the things I'm
about to say would be a failure or in
your own life or in those around you
clap twice if you think being expelled
from school and refused by other school
a failure clockwise if you think
studying three years for a doctoral exam
just to not pass a failure clap twice if
you think learning a foreign language
for five years but still can't speak it
like complete sentences a failure okay
the first person that you might have
pluck clap for was Albert Einstein is he
a failure he is known for his success
success not for his mistakes but today
I'm not going to talk to you about
famous people with that we all know I'm
going to talk to you about Gary green
who missed most of you may not know and
me who you just met a few minutes ago so
when I was little
Gary green went to my school and he
delivered a speech about failures he is
the guy who first introduced me to look
at failures differently he said that he
failed his doctoral exam after studying
three years of special education and
even worse than that his wife and he had
planned a party to celebrate his passing
of the exam but he was informed that he
didn't past and needed to complete an
additional year of graduate school as
you are thinking about what is he going
to do about a party
well I emailed him and asked him just
that he answered by saying it would be
cathartic to have a failure party where
everyone's celebrated various fairly
Australian stories at life and they just
had a great time after hear about this
story my mindset completely changed I
thought to myself now
- exams were not the end of the world so
now I would like you to all think back
to our club twice exercise remember that
last one the person who failed at
learning a foreign language for five
years with me so would you all look at
me right now and call me a failure when
I first went to Argentina a
spanish-speaking country I could not
speak Spanish or English for that matter
I don't know how many of you had the
same experience as I did when I first
started to learn a new language I needed
to do a little Google Translate in my
mind before I could fluently say it out
loud
so I think imagine the first few friends
here were very patient waiting for what
I wanted to say my friend will ask me
what did I eat yesterday oh asking about
food is the hardest question ever even
harder and mine provoking than the
question what is the meaning of life how
am I supposed to know this little green
home tree - ice tree that looks like I
don't know it's called broccoli I would
have to translate beings fried chickens
being broccoli to my friends it's
actually a wonder that we're still
friends after all that would talk anyway
beyond that I see native speakers
strolling through the halls saying
complete sentences and reading attacks
out loud as if they have practice in
front of the mirror the whole afternoon
well I first have to search up Audax
other words I've never seen in my life
click to listen to the pronunciation and
repeat the words several times to
remember I remember for an hour
assignment for school how hard I
practice at home but then when I came to
school the things I was about to say
just couldn't come out of my mouth I
also suffered because of my accent I
remember how people couldn't understand
what I wanted to say and tell me to
spell the words so there I was spelling
HLW ari why don't you how are you well
that kind of conversation would take
forever so I asked my friend to correct
me whenever I sounded weird gradually
people just stop asking me simple words
like chicken or rice at first I thought
I was a failure maybe I was just not
able to speak in public but now when I
look at my
language-learning I looked at all the
experiences I had I realized I wasn't a
failure at all in fact I was quite
successful in not giving up and going to
bed crying every night here's a bit of
an odd transition so just go with me
here never did I think that I will be
talking about my language learning to
talk about the founder of Spanx but here
it is Sara Blakely was talking to Forest
magazine and she defined failure as not
trying but I tried extremely hard to
learn English so in her eyes I was in
that failure thank you for those thanks
Astro teller the head of eggs did a TED
talk about his so-called moonshot
Factory where his team and he needed to
come up with solutions to solve the
world's biggest problems did her work at
first no he said he failed so many times
but then what did he do he celebrated
his failures and then what happened he
succeeded we have heard about so many
famous people successful people talk
about it but what about kids the kids
that you see on the screen during a
class where everyone gets the same
amount of stickers whether they did well
or not so well under exams everyone gets
a high-five when they learn from their
mistakes and things are phrased very
differently in that class
they say they had a whoops moment which
I personally think is a really good
phrase so you can say that idea where
new they'll be using the f-word all this
time I think Pettit weekend is a really
classy and professional event so I like
to honor the cute fifth graders and use
the oops moment from now on hey I
haven't failed you haven't failed we
just had in little oops moment just as
Sara Blakely Gary Greene Astro teller
Albert Einstein and me every one of us
has some awesome in our lives but
however instead of considering them as
failures what if we celebrate them
imagine the world if everyone celebrated
our oops moment imagine if we all have
an oops moment party how will we all
change and how will the world be
different at the
of the day I would like to see with a
little bit of an experiment I would like
to ask the people in the front row
hi can you share it oops moment with me
flunky - oh ok did you learn from it
definitely ok high-five that's great hey
that high-five actually feels really
good so now I would like you to turn to
the people around you and share one oops
moment and high-five them but just one
because I have a speech to finish ok so
as I stand here in front of all of you
today studing even shivering a little I
still consider myself successful even
though I couldn't fall asleep yesterday
and I might have messed up a couple of
lines but why should I care I'm doing
speeches that was not scared of I'm
talking to you all using the language I
wasn't confident in failure
yeah right thank you
[Applause]